[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
funny and then they realize it's not
really
we really do music it's not impossible
to make music with vegetables my name is
Susanna Katya and then I'm a member of
the vegetable orchestra the orchestra
exists since 18 years now if there's
instrument draws the tomato
because you can do sound with tomatoes
but it will be messy for sure we go
shopping on the market first we choose
all the vegetables there we have three
kinds of instruments one is the ready
mate you can just buy it at the market
and play it it's like the pepper it's
cold it's ready already and then there
are the simple instruments like with one
cut or some cuts to get it like that
then with the more complex instruments
we have some that work like normal
instruments you know the pumpkin is the
bass drum and the sound of the pumpkin
is really important after shopping we go
to the venue and start to build
instruments all in all it takes two to
three hours to paint all the instruments
for everybody and then we start with the
soundcheck and since we have new
instruments each time we have to have a
very long soundcheck
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra since there
really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make
the soup during the building process of
the vegetable instruments with the
remaining vegetables when we serve it to
the audience after the concert and it's
also after hearing and seeing us and
smelling the vegetables which will be
intense in there because it's so small
this theater and then you can also eat
it you never get it out of your head
anymore if you're in the orchestra to
look vegetables in another way
[Applause]